they're no longer ready for work that's
steady through college grads fear
starting a career according to a new
damning survey almost half of recent
college graduates are not emotionally
prepared for a nine to five office job
and the other 50 said the survey was too
much work to fill out
according to the poll most workers in
their 20s said they felt burnt out every
week
now we'd go to What's Left of the
greatest Generation ever for a comment
but they're too busy laughing their
balls off at these wusses
and for those in the survey who sought
help 43 suffered from anxiety and 31
percent from depression the others
suffered from low mental cognition from
all those years eating Tide Pods
so who can we blame for this dire
situation well colleges fail to actually
help students enter the workforce
I don't get that Victor but okay
so strange
all right leave it in
come back
I gotta I got a producer in the control
room going I don't care what he says I
don't care what's the blame Biden I'm
putting Biden up there
but it's College because Academia
prioritizes woke agendas over education
so who would have guessed that teaching
kids things
like time was invented by white people
and therefore racists would make them
reluctant to working 40 hours a week
anyway women also seem to report
suffering more office-related mental
struggles than men and that's nothing to
be ashamed of ladies a stapler is a very
complicated piece of equipment
sad
yeah and for struggling women experts
say one mental health trick that they
could use in the workplace is to find a
quiet corner and fold some laundry
would say again
all right Tegan I you know I remember
when I was graduating from college I was
terrified of going to work but you get
over that on your first or second day is
this any different are they different
now
no they're hungover and high as hell
foreign
it's not that they're stressed out by an
eight-hour day they're just it's an
extension of college they haven't you
you figure it out by 29 or when you get
fired and have to move back in with Mama
and Daddy yeah that's how it so it's no
different whether they're Zoomers or not
yeah they're just they want to be at
home napping watching it's Flora Bama
Shore I mean I am pro-legalization but
there is like I always said that you
know you shouldn't start smoking pot
until you've already accomplished
something because you won't accomplish
you will not accomplish anything if you
if you get it reversed
if you start smoking pot you're not
going to get that great job but if you
get that great job then the pot becomes
like your martini
you come home you smoke a little and
then everything's great but if you start
if you do it I know so many people that
got it reversed and they amount to
nothing because all they do they've
baked and baked for for like 20 years
before they know it they couldn't get a
job and I'm not talking about you
Shannon because you
[Applause]
does this ring true to you this that the
problem with kids today I hate we sound
so old I know when we're like
um I just remember first of all law
school was hell on Earth and then I came
through that and I went to work for my
firm as a young associate and it's like
you're working 100 hours a week or else
so I have a hard time relating to this
when they say burnout but like isn't
that what your 20s are supposed to be
they just fried all the time you don't
have any money it's hard to put things
together like the 20s are not supposed
to be like you've won the lottery and
you're working 25 hours a week you're
supposed to work
for people like me who terrify you
because that's what happened to me when
I was younger oh you know what's really
weirdly is when you're like you it's the
first time you were working with people
that are older than you and you realize
that they're not smart like as a kid you
always thought that adults were smart
and then you get to a workplace and all
of a sudden you're next to some 50 year
old dude who's just like an idiot
and I'm not talking you said it not me
she won't be here
what if these kids are right maybe we're
over emphasizing work huh maybe because
of Automation and robots and artificial
intelligence we're supposed to follow
our dreams literally now or maybe we're
raising these kids to be lazy pansies
Maybe maybe the covid pandemic had for
years these kids going through high
school and maybe in a college where they
had all sorts of time off they didn't
have to take tests and they had they
were able to come up with all sorts of
excuses even the remote work a lot of
people just don't even want to show up
to work and they should and they feel
like they're entitled to it there's a
sense of entitlement coming out of the
pandemic I don't know what the Bible
says on this
I was in the 82nd Airborne Division and
there was a saying there suck it up
Airborne yeah and and you have a job you
have a mission to accomplish you'll work
long hours in that job we don't want to
hear your complaints and something has
happened in the last few years where
this sense of entitlement they're just
they're not working hard I've heard Work
Hard Play Hard some people are work hard
work hard this is a generation of Play
Hard Play Hard
suck it up airborne
I'm gonna use that tonight you know I
also would add that I I would also
I would add identity politics which is
uh training people not to work with
others like you cannot cooperate now
with people that are different from you
and so everybody's getting splintered
off into their own groups and that's
considered an achievement so it's like
it used to be everybody had to work
together now with identity politics your
identity comes before cooperation cat
don't you agree with me
okay well
I don't think that I've ever been
emotionally prepared yeah okay yeah I
mean depression anxiety I I have these
things right I I have mental health
stuff I deal with but that's the thing
is you deal with it uh it's not your
fault if you have these sort of issues
but it is your responsibility to deal
with them
um you know if you are going to expect
that the world is going to revolve
around you and your sensibilities and
your feelings and your issues that's not
something that deserves compassion
because you're just being selfish at
that point that's being selfish you know
who always thought the world were
revolved around them the Sun
think about that
tonight
suck it up airborne
[Applause]
that's gonna be my catchphrase
that's my catchphrase hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else